hey everybody you guys were requesting a
video all about Black Panthers abilities
Marvel actually explained how they're
going to work in the MCU so this is
going to be a breakdown there's a Marvel
giveaway that's going on right now for
those spider-man action figures I need a
Black Panther giveaway so you guys feel
free to recommend Black Panther stuff
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber or leave a comment on this
video but since Doctor Strange we've
seen some really weird stuff in the
Marvel Universe so you don't have to
explain everybody's powers using the
technology of Tony Stark the way they're
doing with all the spider-man Home
Coming gear in the news suit even though
he's gotten the spider bite so
technically they're metahumans but they
don't use the word mutant they use the
term enhanced which is a good way to
describe Black Panther but a lot of his
physical abilities Super Soldier Captain
America style flow from vibranium
interestingly enough so if you haven't
read a lot of the comics vibranium is
the core of Wakanda 's economy their
cultural heritage is enabled them to be
so self-contained and free from outside
influence that what you get when you see
the beginning of the trailer and he
walks into warrior falls here is a look
at a society that hasn't been affected
by the mick world effect and I'll
explain some of the technology to
because you see some devices on his
wrist there's a lot of what condom
technology that just like Asgardian
technology looks very old-timey but is
actually super advanced when new Black
Panthers take the mantle from the
previous king or queen as it may be
because Sheree was black panther in the
comics they take the arch shaped herb
and it helps form the bond with the
Panther God that gives them their powers
so it's more mystical in nature in the
comics but with the Marvel movies have
done is make it a little more practical
Kevin Feige says that's partially
spiritual so it says partially we
certainly don't call it magic
but there's vibranium that has been
interwoven with that soil in the lands
for thousands of years so there's all
these other things going on with it so
there is a spiritual aspect to his
powers as well as a biological aspect so
the herb itself actually gives him
heightened instincts enhanced abilities
it makes it a superhuman but not
everybody takes it so other members of
the royal family don't get to ingest
that herb so cherie for instance in the
tray
is enhanced by her own technology she's
a really awesome Tony Stark type
character that innovates with their
vibranium technology finds new uses for
it the lineage of the Panther is a
little more straightforward you take the
mantle you take the herb you form a bond
with this other world a spiritual
Panther god I'll be really interested to
see how they deal with that because they
do get into the afterlife the de Jala
the spiritual plane but also they
literally just eat a plant that's been
growing in vibranium tainted soil for
thousands of years the important thing
that they don't really tell you though
is that the heart-shaped herb only grows
from the heart tree which is in the
necropolis here so if you look in the
brand-new comic the way they put it down
here explains a little bit better it's a
very sacred place that only black
panther and other really high-ranking
people can go so not just anybody could
walk in there and ingest the herb and
get those powers so what you have is you
have like a Captain America level person
wearing a lot of vibranium Tech that's
gone way beyond what Stark has done and
you get your badass Black Panther so
that's why he can move so much quicker
but the suits that he wears are just as
good as anything that Stark would wear
and it's form-fitting in light weight
don't even get started on this cityscape
here if you think the ships that you see
in guardians of the galaxy or advance
they're not quite as advanced to say
like the Nova Corps or the Kree they're
not quite there yet but that whole pitch
the idea of El Dorado this mythical city
that's so much better than everywhere
else so I know a lot of you are like hey
wait a minute how come they have an
address this in the Thor movies probably
because he doesn't care that much about
humans unless something is really wrong
they're concerned with much bigger
galactic things and arune metal is just
as good as vibranium so it's like when
you see Black Panther scratch Captain
America's vibranium shield with his
vibranium claws he wouldn't be able to
scratch Thor's hammer because the hammer
is enchanted but if he went up against a
normal Asgardian soldier yeah he'd be
able to claw the hell out of their metal
armor moving into the technological side
of things this is where it gets even
more interesting because you look at him
and it looks like a normal cloth suit
like you see in the comics but we know
because of spider-man homecoming is it
just because the mask for instance looks
like it's cloth doesn't mean that you
don't have a digital readout inside
there so we haven't been inside
Black Panthers mask it and I think
that's mostly just so they don't give
away too many things before the movie
but as you've seen in the comics part of
his suit is actually extremely style
building itself around him so part of
its practical like he climbs into a pair
of trunks but the rest of it just comes
out from that small piece the same way
that Iron Man's glove manifests from
that little wristwatch looking device I
don't think they're going to do anything
that crazy in the movie I think it's
going to be closer to what you see in
spider-man homecoming like he actually
climbs into a suit it just has a lot of
technology built into it some of you may
have noticed in these UN scenes that
he's wearing the Komodo beads what those
are sort of like a ceremonial highly
advanced AI device that allows them to
access wakanda's database but they only
work inside Wakanda that require
vibranium
so there's vibranium in the soil what
happens is is when they're in proximity
the Komodo beads activate they feed off
that energy so when they leave Wakanda
it'd be like taking the battery out of
your iPhone they just look like normal
beads when he's walking around in the
world but when he's inside Wakanda
there's a holographic displays it'll
project it gives him access to
everything it's sort of like his version
of Friday so Stark has Holograms that'll
project from his gear where he can talk
to it he can see things he can interact
with the Holograms Black Panther has
that too but it has a much more
ceremonial look to it so that's what
these are but the really cool thing I
think is that the fact that they're
powered by vibranium so whenever you're
near vibranium they just activate
automatically the weakness being that if
you're not near vibranium they're not
going to work so what you'll see is is
when they're and will Kondo fighting
you'll probably see him use the hollow
display but it goes beyond this - this
is the tribal aspect to it so you've
seen a lot of tribal elements in the
trailer there's a lot of culture of
Wakanda that's gone untouched so you see
the Asgardian culture has been preserved
even though they're highly advanced
beings they have the Rainbow Bridge so a
lot of their practices are very ancient
but they've grown super advanced so it's
the same thing with what content society
what happens is is what content citizens
grow older and they go through life
changes achievements they go through
manhood or womanhood ceremonies they
gain new beads that have different
technological functions
so there's beads that store personal
data they're bees the do other thing
as you sort of unlock achievements so
like Black Panther would have special
beads because he's the king of Wakanda
that other normal citizens wouldn't have
so they're all very personalized to your
own life's journey so I think that's
what makes Black Panthers a movie so
much more interesting than just another
Iron Man movie you get all this really
cool technology but there's this
cultural heritage aspect to the way they
develop technology and use it that goes
all the way back to his basic powers the
reason why he takes up the Panther
mantle their connection with the Panther
God their connection with the afterlife
in the spirit realm so I know a lot of
you now are like hey wait a minute if
this technology is so advanced and so
great how come Tony Stark doesn't know
about it how come Everett Ross who's
working with the world security council
doesn't know about it
it's just because Wakanda has been so
isolated and protected from the outside
world for thousands of years and I know
a lot of you are asking about this map
of India and the United Nations scene
it's glowing red like something really
bad happened if black panther has to
answer for it they have highly advanced
technology probably pretty crazy
weaponry somebody probably steal
something and uses it to attack or do
something really bad in India so Black
Panther has to answer for that we're
trying to be better members of the
global community now so he has to
navigate those politics while at the
same time learning to be a king keeping
these other big tribes of Wakanda from
getting rid of him and they did explain
that this person in green here that
people have been asking about he's just
a leader of the biggest tribe in Wakanda
so he's one person who could turn the
populace against Black Panther if he
wanted to there's a whole bunch of Black
Panther comic-book stuff that we can
talk about we can talk about infinity
war stuff he posted this picture with
the Hulk
there is a badass what Condon Hulkbuster
that he wears
during the recent run so leave all your
requests for bonus videos I'll probably
do another video about kill monger the
big villain there's a big thing with the
warrior fall sequence they tease in the
trailer is a big part of the black
panther comics so I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post my next Marvel video
while you wait for that you can click
here to re-watch the trailer and you can
click here for brand new spider-man
homecoming
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I will see you guys tonight